I'm John Nelson and I'm an assistant scout master with Troop 947 in Westchester Ohio.
This addition to the Scout Master podcast is sponsored by backers like me
And now the old scout master.
So you go to? you go to summer camp or a round table or a big meeting
and there's lots of scouters there and everybody's talking to one another.
How do you know if you're talking to a commissioner?
It's going to be easy, because that's among the first things that they will tell you.
Okay, my apologies to commissioners everywhere.
Hey, this is podcast number 236..
Welcome back to the Scout Master podcast. This is Clark Green.
Let's take a look at the mailbag
We heard from Brent Dixon, who is an assistant scout master with Troop 192
in the Central Florida Council.
He wrote in to say thanks for all you do to inspire and give us great ideas
and better ways to help our scouts enjoy the journey of scouting.
I have been trying to find a song or audio clip unsuccessfully for a while now,
and I'm hoping you can help me. a few years ago on your podcast,
You used to play a clip that I think is called:
He's my all time favorite Boy Scout.
I would love to get hold of that song.
It's catchy and fun.
I think the scouts would enjoy it.
Well, Brent, I sent you a link to that song and I'll also have one
in the post that contains this podcast,
And the song is called Scout Boy.
It's easy to find.
You can buy it on Amazon for a buck
And, yeah, it's one of my favorite songs too.
Shall we hear a little bit? right now
There's just a little bit, which is usually enough for everybody.
Mike Martin is an assistant scout master with Troop 186..
Thanks for all you do with the website and all the attachments to it.
It's a great resource.
I'm writing to ask what your recommendation would be for a patrol stove.
I'd like something small, probably like one burner, that can fit into
a small patrol box.
Well, thanks for your kind words, Mike
It's. I'm always happy to hear that people find things at scoutmastercgcom useful.
I'm going to share a link with you to a wood burning stove called the Echo Zoom.
It's not real tiny, but we bought these three or four years ago for our patrols
and they work great and they burn wood,
So you don't have to worry about gas canisters or anything like that.
And there's a new one that my buddy Walter just told me about that.
I'm going to do a post on this week,
So keep an eye on scoutmastercgcom.
Heard from Paul Fife who said: hello, I let my troop choose their own
patrols for the first time on Monday night.
I think it scared them, but I look forward to seeing how things
changed.
Thank you for your advice.
Well, Paul, that's the way it works and it is a little scary at first.
And you know, the sweet spot, where we want to be most of the time
as a scouters is to be just a little bit uncertain,
Not to really know what's coming next, because a lot of times that
means that our scouts are invested in making decisions and running
their troop, and that's really what we want to see.
Jeff Freeman got in touch and he said: may I borrow images from
your site when quoting parts of it or sharing links on my own
blog? and my reply to Jeff was, of course- and I got a look
at his blog and actually posted about it this past week.
Go to scoutmastercgcom.
You'll see a link in the post: Jeff scouting blog.
Take a look at it.
I really enjoy reading blogs by other scouters who are
keeping track of what they're doing and offering their
opinions and their ideas.
So check out Jeff scouting blog
And, as I often say, everything that we do at scoutmastercgcom
is designed and offered to advance the cause of scouting.
So share it, use it.
You don't really need my permission to do so.
As long as you send a link back to us, we're happy to
have you use it.
Well, let's see
Over the past week that several posts- one was in reply to
a just this random comment I saw- about whether or not I was
lucky to have a bunch of older boys who run the troop
for me.
Well, I've been very fortunate to work with a lot of really
great young people. but read that post because it's
not all luck.
No, not at all.
And see replied in the comments.
Clark, yes, it's true that younger scouts are capable
to, because I did mention that in that post.
It's not just older scouts who are capable of taking
on leadership positions and positions of responsibility.
Younger scouts can do it too. and see went on to say
I have more than once had to remind an older scout
that they started leading about the same age as the
scout who they currently think is too young.
Been there, done that.
There's another benefit that's not readily apparent
about youth leading their troop and no doubt you know
about it, but I think it's worth mentioning.
I suspect you really do have more older scouts than
other troops.
I know we do because we use the patrol method.
We have about 50% high school age scouts.
They stay with us because they feel they're achieving
something,
They have actual responsibility by planning, leading
and instructing other scouts.
And yeah, I agree,
You know, once scouts hit that 13,, 14 year old age,
they're not very interested in sitting and listening
to you talk anymore.
What, what they're really interested in is having a
stake in the action, the responsibility of leadership.
That's what has always been the older boy program
and scouting.
It's no big secret. but a lot of times we find
that adults are taking all those responsibilities
and the scouts really don't have all that much to
do and they go find other things to do.
Let's see another post. this past week was-
Well, it was a little bit of a humorous post about the
secret laws of adolescents.
And if you haven't seen that and you want to laugh,
go ahead scoutmastercgcom and look for that post-
the secret laws of adolescents- and see if you remember
them.
And if you remember any others that I didn't include
in that post, get in touch with me.
Hey, if you're a regular reader and listener,
if the information and the ideas that we offer have
helped you, you can return the favor by making a
one time contribution as a scoutmastercgcom backer.
The funds we get from backers go towards the
expenses of producing and publishing the blog posts
and the podcasts and the videos and all the other
resources that are accessible to scouts all over
the world.
It's pretty easy to do. go to scoutmastercgcom,
click the support link at the top of the page.
You can choose any level of support and some of
those entitle you to premiums like autograph copies
of my books.
So take a moment to do that
If you haven't already. normally I take a little
time to thank people who've signed up to be backers
since the previous podcast, but I got to tell you
this week nobody did, and you know that's fine.
Sometimes things are a little slow, but if you
have a chance this week and you have not yet become
a backer and you'd like to do so, hit scoutmastercgcom,
go to the support link.
You'll find out exactly how to do that
In this week's scoutmaster podcast in scoutmastership,
in seven minutes or less,
We have our second installment of a four part
series on the patrol method and this is going to
discuss the adult role when it comes to the patrol
method. and then we've got an email question to answer
and that's going to take up the remainder of the
podcast.
So let's get started.
Shall we scoutmastership? in seven minutes or less,
This is our second installment about the patrol
method.
We talked about the character school a little bit
last week and tried to describe exactly why the
patrol method is important and let's talk about the
adult role of putting the patrol method into
practice. and to do that,
I want you to imagine a bus tour of some important
city where you're seated in the air conditioned
comfort of a motor coach and you're going to
listen to the guide explain each landmark in
detail. right, the guide has a script, they- and we
sit there behind our tinted windows and we look to
the left and we look to the right,
We listen to the guide and there's so much
explaining going on that there's not a whole
lot of time left for questions. soon
The tour is over, you know, and and we we
think that we've learned some things, but we've
basically been sitting in this nice air conditioned
bus just looking at things. now contrast that
tour with a hike led by another knowledgeable
guide. now this guy takes up the rear of our
group and let's us find our way forward. where
the path branches, he'll tell us which way to go
if we ask, and if we can't figure it out
on our own, he doesn't mind if we stop now
and then to admire a flower taking the view,
and it will happily tell us what we're
looking at if we ask. but he's not going
to volunteer a whole lot of information.
he's not going to be at the head of the
group telling us what happens next. he'll
drop a hint here or there and he'll
answer our questions. and you know what?
we may miss some things along the way,
we may pass by some interesting things,
but our group will probably get more out
of what we discovered on the hike
and asked about then, the things that
the guide on the bus told us about. as
you may imagine, guiding scouts using the
patrol method is more like the hike than
the bus tour. does that make sense? it's a
gentle push in the right direction rather
than dragging them along. it's a suggestion
rather than a command. it's a question
asked rather than an answer given. so
the key thought is: the adult role in the
patrol method is more responsive than
directive. each group of scouts is
different, so how we play our role is a
response to their development, the
dynamics of the group and their abilities.
there's a big difference between guiding
and coercing. if we follow the metaphor I
started with, our group of hikers has some
idea of where they want to go and the
guide is responding to them rather than
determining what we're going to be
interested in. we ought to respond to
the interests of our scouts rather than
determining what they should be
interested in. the field of play is
scouting. we guide them within that
context and we train them to follow the
program. now our role in scouting is
important, but we're not in the
leadership structure. we aren't even on
the chart. we have a senior patrol
leader. we have patrol leaders. scouts
form their own patrols. they elect their
senior patrol leader and patrol leaders.
we don't appoint them. we respond to
the choices made by the scouts and start
guiding the leaders they selected. now,
last week we talked about decorations
and indicators that we think the
content of meetings and camping trips
and things like that are all important,
but they're actually just decorative.
we think that metrics of attendance
and membership and fundraising and
advancement are important, but these
are just indicators. there are troops
where the patrol method is watered down
to this kind of administrative nicety,
just a way to divide scouts into more
manageable groups and provide
figurative leadership positions for
scouts. but when we really put the
patrol method into practice, that
kind of thing changes drastically.
since people are usually resistant
to the dramatic change, there are going
to be objections. and then the third
in this series of four talks about
the patrol method. we're going to talk
about those objections, so let's
review where we are. so far. we know
the patrol method is the way scouting
works. it's not just one that we can
choose from a menu of choices about
how scouting works. we're always using
the patrol method and now we ought
to understand the adults role in
it. we're really not on the leadership
chart. we're not there leading the
patrol. we're not there coercing
the actions of scouts. we're putting
them on a path, we're describing the
path to them, we're giving them a map
and we're following their lead.
they're going to elect their own
leaders, they're going to shape and
form their own patrols and they're
going to move things forward. and in
my experience that's vastly
different than the way the patrol
method is practiced in a lot of
places. so when we begin suggesting
that this is the way to do it,
they're going to be some objections.
next week we'll talk about those.
there's a quarter master. everybody
knows there's a song about him. this
is how it goes. just a little bit he
doesn't mean a thing, but when the
boys are marching how they love to
sing, there were mice- mice eating up
the rice in the stores. in the stores
there were rats- rats big as blooming
cats in the quarter master store. my
eyes are dim. I cannot see. I have not
brought my specs with me. I have not
brought my specs with me.
email that is, folks, and here's an answer
to one of your emails. I received this
email in the past week and I'm really
interested in talking about it because
I think it's a great expression of what
a lot of people feel. and the author of
the email asked to have their name
withheld, so I'm doing that. but they
got in touch with me and said: I had
a terrific experience in scouting as
a youth. my son is now a Cub Scout and
I am his den leader. like many parents,
I'm concerned that my son may lose
interest in scouting over the years,
because he really enjoys sports and
there are so many other things out
there that it seems like we're fighting
an uphill battle sometimes. do you have
any suggestions for keeping him engaged?
it seems to me sometimes like scouting
has become the alternative activity
for children who don't play sports. do
you see that as well? it seems like in
Cub Scout recruiting we focus a lot on
outdoor activities and my son enjoys
that, but the advancement requirements
seem focused around indoor activities
like crafts and things like that. any
ideas you have on this would be much
appreciate. I'd love for him to have
an experience as great as mine. while
I really appreciate your email and I
think one of the most important
things Cub Scout leaders can learn and
apply to their work is that scouting
is a progressive program. in the BSA we
have tiger cubs. is that where we starting
Cub Scouts and you're working right
along with a parent throughout the year
that you are a tiger cub? then the next
year you become a wolf- and family
involvement is still very important- and
the next year become a bear and you
begin working more with a den leader.
then you did as a wolf and we blows.
you learn to work more with each other
based on the patrol method, but the
den leader is still very important
in a scout troop. you're working together
with your fellow scouts to lead
yourselves, with progressively less
adult oversight and inventures. you're
working with your fellow scouts to
plan, lead and present all the
activities. each of these steps along
the way the program presents progressive
opportunities for outdoor experiences
and age appropriate advancement
challenges. now, as you know, there's more
indoor activities involved with cubs
and these are designed to be age
appropriate and provide plenty of
opportunities to work on things with
your family and with your den
leader. but as boys become more
capable to enjoy camping, those
opportunities increase. the other really
important thing to remember is that
all of this, all the Cub Scout crafts
and all the activities in the badges,
the camping and the adventure, they
all have an ulterior motive, don't
they? and that ulterior motive is
forming character. we need to keep our
eye on that aim. sometimes it gets a
little lost in the excitement and
things get a little off track. most of
the folks who volunteer to lead Cub
Scouts are really energetic, engaged
and driven people. they have to be,
because you know that that's intense
work and sometimes all of this
energy and engagement and drive can
translate into an all or nothing
approach or going just kind of a little
over the top with things. so, as
you're working with your son as
his den leader, it's important to
have a broad perspective of the
entire program and to understand
where you are on the trail of this
progression. don't push them forward,
don't hold them back. just stay
within the context of the program.
now, as for sports and the myriad of
other things that are available to
children, I think it's important to
understand we are never in competition
with these activities. we cooperate
with them. scouting is never an all or
nothing activity. when a family
chooses scouting, it ought to be
understood. they choose all of the
above. we want our scouts out doing
things in their schools and
communities. we want them taking
the character that they are forming
in scouts and applying what they
have learned in scouts to sports,
to band, to all the clubs and all
the other activities they can be
involved in. now I know this creates
scheduling conflicts and things
like that, and it's our challenge to
work with those things, but we
really need to keep our eye on the
aim. we're forming character and the
scouts are taking that character
out into the community, out to their
school. that's what we really want
to see happening. so if we consider
that we're in competition with
the other things in a scouts life,
I think we get ourselves mixed up.
we don't need to be in competition
with any of that, we're cooperating
with it. somewhere around the 7th
grade, our boy wanted to quit scouts
and at that age, seriously, they're
still waking up in a new world.
every day they're not quite sure
what's going on around them.
sometimes they've got all kinds of
ideas and energy and it's a
wonderful, wonderful, yet challenging
age, isn't it? and you know, what
we said was that scouts was not
going to be an option. it was
something that he was going to do.
now that sounds a little heavy-handed.
maybe it is, I don't know. but we
did this because we understood
two things: the value of the
scouting program and his
participation in it, and the
vicissitudes of those years of
adolescents. they're going to try
out all kinds of things and
that's fine. but what they're
looking for a lot of times in
that is they're looking for some
kind of a response that says: you
know, scouts is something that
you're going to do. you might not
like it all the time, and you
know what he didn't. he griped and
complained for a month or two. but
once he found out we met business,
he kind of acquiesced and he did
what he had to do and you know
what he found? he found that he
loved it anyway. subsequently he
went on to become an Eagle Scout
and he'll tell you today, if
you ask him, he wouldn't have had
at any other way. and you know
I'm kind of glossing over this-
and I understand that managing
a child's schedule and giving
them some direction, that's a
really tough job for parents. we
really want them to be happy, we
want them to have the advantage
of all these different opportunities
and activities, but at the same
time we have to help them make
decisions. if you decide your
child is going to be a scout,
stick with it. there is no
practical way they're going to
be able to do everything and
it's up to us to help them
sort things out. our son came
home from some scout activities
and complained about having to do
them. he came from from others
that were- quote the best time
I've ever had in my life,
unquote- wishing he could do
them all over again. he had the
same kind of reactions with
school. he wasn't all that
interested in sports but he
was very involved with other
clubs and activities we helped
him choose and manage and we
had to say no a few times.
that's what parents do, and
we do that simply because
children don't have the kind
of experience that helps them
make an informed decision. and
all of this begins to answer
the question in this email:
how do I keep him involved?
well, you decide that this is
what you're going to do and
you stick with the decision.
of course, every child is going
to show interest or ability
for things outside of scouting
and you're going to be called
on to kind of manage that
involvement and you know
what. you may have to change
course if things aren't
working out as you expected.
but that's not something you
can decide on today. you're
going to have to cross that bridge
when you get to it. you're
going to be at loggerheads
with your child sometimes,
but that's to be expected.
not every child is going to stay
in school. if they had the
choice right- and to tell you
the truth, how many of us,
for that matter, would really
rather not going to work
tomorrow morning? okay, there
are some things that we do.
it's not necessary that we do
them, because they're the most
engaging, exciting and wonderful
things that we've ever done
in our lives, but because we
know that they're the right
things to do. our boy is 30
now. he and his wife have a little
girl and it's still sinking
in that I am actually a
grandparent. wow, the one thing
that nobody has any way
of understanding, unless
they have older children, is
how fast childhood goes by.
think about this for a moment.
you're going to have a child
and they're going to progress
through all the wonderful
and challenging stages of growing
up. at some point they're
out on their own and then
you know what like. there's a
lot of life left after that
and those years where you have
the advantage of working
along with them in a program
like scouting. they're very,
very short in comparison to
what comes after, and I have
never run into anybody
who regretted spending too
much time with their child
and scouts. never I've talked
to those who wish they had
realized how fast this was all
going to go by and that
they had spent a great deal
more. I hope that helps answer
the question and address
some of your concerns.
if you have a question
about scouting and like a little
advice, you can get in touch.
you're going to find out how
to do that in just a moment.
thanks so much for listening
to this 236th edition
of the scoutmaster podcast.
here's how you can keep in touch.
read the blog at scoutmastercgcom
and, while you're there,
you can receive updates
to the blog by email.
get the scoutmaster app
on Google Play
or at the iTunes app store
and that way you can
have all the resources
that we create right there
at your fingertips.
you can experience
the wonders of scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama
of social media outlets.
that's right.
join the 6500 folks
who like Scoutmaster blog
on Facebook.
tweet along with the chorus
of 1100 tweeters on Twitter.
pin the poultry tuna's pictures
proffered publicly,
with 1600 other prolific
pinners on Pinterest.
you can watch us at
scoutmastercg on YouTube
and join the 400 odd folks
who form the exclusive scoutmaster
CG circle on Google Plus.
but wait,
I can't face Facebook.
Twitter makes me better.
I have no interest in Pinterest.
I don't put the? U in YouTube.
I'm a minus
when it comes to Google Plus.
is that you?
that's okay, Bunky.
zoom into the late 90s
and send me an email.
that's right.
you can get in touch with me,
Clark Green,
with your comments and questions
and your wild ideas
at Clark at scoutmastercgcom.
CLA, RKE
at scoutmastercgcom.
all that remains is for me to tell you,
the Scoutmaster blog
and the Scoutmaster podcast
are not official publications
of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed
or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America
or any other scouting organization
for that matter.
I'm sure
they have much more important things to do.
no, it's just me talking into a microphone
trying to lend a hand to scout leaders
and, you know,
have a little bit of fun
as I do so.
and speaking of fun,
here's our founder,
Sir Robert Baden-Powell.
Sir Robert,
good luck to you
and good camping
boy. thank you, sir,
until next time, everyone.